hello and welcome to the agenda next
week we're in Strasburg for the plenary
where lots of special guests are
expected let's take a look at what's on
offer blessing Strasburg with his
presence a formal setting of biblical
proportions as his Holiness Pope Francis
addresses the plenary on Tuesday it's
been 26 years since Jean Paul the second
last visited the Parliament so there's
huge excitement for the visit of Pope
Francis after his speech in the plenary
where he's expected to talk about
European values the Pope will then make
a stop off at the Council of Europe you
can follow all the proceedings live on
the website over now to another
prestigious event this sakharov prize in
October President of the Parliament
Martin Schulz announced the recipient of
this year's award was dr. Dennis mcquaig
a by a unanimous vote the 59 your
gynecologist has worked tirelessly to
help thousands of gang rape victims in
the Democratic Republic of Congo he's
setting at the hospital in the 1990s to
help treat those victims but standing up
for the most vulnerable came at a price
when two years ago an assassination
attempt was made against him dr.
McGregor will be awarded the sakharov
prize for freedom of thought on
Wednesday we do total pay us to also new
diesel for Europe RTV traveled to Congo
and that report will be available later
on this month and don't forget on
Thursday there will be a vote on the
motion of censure against the European
Commission after its president
jean-claude Juncker was accused of
giving favorable tax breaks to
multinationals when he was prime
minister of Luxembourg well the
Commission have to resign find out on
Thursday over now to a summit after a
summit as a 28 joint EU in african
caribbean and pacific countries
conference gets underway on the advent
of december top of their agenda will be
the Ebola crisis find out more when that
kicks off on the following monday and
just as the EU a
p conference kicks off in strasbourg at
the very same time peru hosts the UN
climate change conference in lima
leaders will gather to continue to hash
out an agreement on climate change and
that's all we have this agenda take care
and enjoy the week